tell me something that I just heard
about you
I didn't realize how heavily you were
into making movies but you
um you got all the tattoos removed from
your arms yeah I took them up mine let
me see because you didn't you were tired
of being in the movies and having them
removed wow but doesn't that leave scars
but it comes back it like it depends on
how
who you actually went to actually do it
like people go to the wrong places and I
heard it's extremely painful it is to
get your tattoos removed it's more
painful than putting it on really and
how long a process is that isn't it
months yeah it'll probably take about a
year before it to be completely out you
know but it's easier to cover it with
makeup like like if you had a six
o'clock call time I'd have to be in it
on set two o'clock in the morning just
to cover yeah just to cover your arms
right wow so you said I'm gonna go to a
doctor I'm gonna have a remote now you
were pretty heavily tattooed on your
arms around your arms I took them off
yeah and what does it look like let me
see
see I see you see it's almost like
somebody like little pigments is knocked
out of it they got to come back in right
yeah wow on his arm and it's fading not
that bad but man that that sounds very
very painful uh you say that you can cry
on command does that come in handy in
the movies
yeah different points I I um
I could do it now okay yeah let me see
you cry because I I've always I've
always admired actors who can do this
I don't know if I could do it for you
right now yeah well well did you
discover this or did uh I mean how did
you know you could do that
it's just different roles that I had to
play yeah but you discovered on
set like what do you think about to make
you cry just old stuff childhood stuff
think about what your father no I don't
know my father that's what I'm saying
like do you ever think about it I don't
know my father and then you start to cry
ah just I I had like a pretty rough
childhood I know you know what do you
think about
to get you going
oh oh different like little little
things that well not little but
small portions of my experience all
right like give me something that makes
you cry
oh man
just I mean well just the transition I
have a grandmother dying not going into
my grandmother's home after my mom
passed that makes you cry yeah that was
a real uncomfortable feeling for me
because you didn't want to live with
your grandmother you want to live with
your mom yeah and that was just
like my mom's one or not she was the
only one of my grandmother's nine
children who passed away uh were you
angry about that
oh no what how old were you I was like
eight years old you lost your mother
when you were eight yeah that's tough my
mother lost her mother when she was nine
I don't think she's ever gone there it
is you're crying there it is 50's got it
going
you got the tears going
you are a good actor
or is it real
whoa
good for you wow you just did it
I mean you had him going yeah you
couldn't do that Howard hell no he's a
better actor than you he might be when I
did my movie huh there was a scene where
I had to cry they um they put
they put onions on it
I cried
foreign